hey youtubers this Charlie it has been a
crazy day first off I just quit my job
this is like my first day as a full-time
YouTube creator there were Star Wars
spoilers all across the morning and I
just got excused from jury duty that's a
little bit of a bonus this video is
gonna be all about the episode 7 info
dump this morning there's new
stormtrooper designs the supposed
villains and even the main villain with
some plot details leaked and my friend
even got to do really awesome podcast
with Rian Johnson who's gonna be writing
and directing Star Wars Episode 8 so
Lucasfilm has said nothing official
about any of those supposes stuff that
was posting this morning any of the
pictures the concept art or the story
details and I don't expect them to but I
will say whenever I talk about each of
them which of the rumors I think are
more plausible but if you're finding me
for the first time I'm gonna be doing
weekly rebels videos whenever that
starts airing be sure to subscribe to
get everything that's actually gonna be
in October so let's start with the
confirmed stuff first the new
stormtrooper designs just like the
original trilogy there are a few
variations there's the normal armor and
then there's the desert climate armor
those are the only ones we've seen so
far but there could be more variations
it's just a sleeker more modernized
design I know a lot of you were asking
on Twitter why they needed to change the
classic theme really I just think it's
JJ Abrams visually conveying that a lot
of time has passed then certain things
have evolved everything is really close
to what you remember it just looks like
a few things have been updated Aztec has
evolved inside the Star Wars universe
Episode seven is supposed to take place
around thirty years after Return of the
Jedi just to put a little scale on it a
lot of you are also asking what the role
the Empire is in the new trilogy and
what has changed since Return of the
Jedi
yes went down and the Empire got
its ass handed to it at the Battle of
Endor but the Empire didn't take all
their resources there there's still
millions of Imperial soldiers all over
the galaxy with their own fleets and
resources so whenever I get to the
potential villains spoilery part I'll
talk about it more specifically but
basically the Empire is still around
it's just that a lot of that top brass
has changed it's like Walmart you know
just because a few executives go away
doesn't mean the new ones don't step in
to fill the vacuum the bureaucracy of
the Empire was all about advancement
there's always gonna be someone younger
and more evil ready to steal your job
when you get thrown down an elevator
shaft
now let's talk about the supposed to
villain and I'll say spoiler warning
just because even though it's a rumor it
could be potentially spoilery and
because you guys requested it I'll add
like a little spoiler bug somewhere here
on the screen
while those boys are going on I'll wait
just a sec before I start okay everybody
ready let's go the big rumor is that a
bunch of crew members from the movie
were being laid off recently and it led
to some villain leaks along with some
other stuff the details being that the
inquisitors are the big antagonists of
the movie and the main villain is the
head Inquisitor
there's no info about his name or if
he's tied to the Inquisitor from Star
Wars rebels but supposedly that picture
JJ Abrams tweeted last week the one with
the Droid Han
supposedly that belongs to the main
villain it's his hand as in he's a
mostly cybernetic Sith Inquisitor this
is supposedly an image of him no idea if
it's fan made or real concept art but it
was sweeping the interwebs all morning
with taka spoilers if it's true picture
him is being like a darker grittier
version of Darth Vader like whenever
Vader's head piece came off and you saw
all the machine parts covering his skull
JJ Abrams totally changed the Klingon so
of course his version of a Darth Vader
type character would look a little bit
different to the real question though is
are they going to humanize them like
they did with Darth Vader and Empire and
Return of the Jedi here's why I think
the rumor is true or at least partially
true using the inquisitors in the new
film lines up with what Lucasfilm has
said about rebels being canon and
characters from the cartoon being
featured in the films so I know I just
made a lot of Darth Vader references
supposedly he's also going to get a
small cameo in a flashback that's going
to tie in with the Sith inquisitors Luke
Skywalker is supposed to have a
monologue and flashback explaining how
Vader started using the inquisitors to
hunt down the Jedi which is already
happening in the cartoon this fall the
reason this Darth Vader rumor is a big
deal is because everyone said that he
was not gonna be in the movie he's not
coming back to life he's just gonna get
a small cameo he's dead they're not
changing that but they are changing the
Sith rule of two as in the inquisitors
will be reckoned into the original
trilogy it's just a way for them to
explain hey this group of bad guys has
been working with Vader and the Emperor
the whole time and just because Vader
and the Emperor died doesn't mean that
the inquisitors stopped what they were
doing we don't know everything about the
story yet but it sounds like maybe the
Sith inquisitors as a group generally
seize control the Empire after the death
of the Emperor and Vader supposedly Leia
is also supposed to get flashbacks to
Alderaan you know young Leia flashback
they tie in with that story too that's
why Carrie Fisher's real-life daughter
was cast in the movie for that young
Leia flashback cameo all the flashback
talk in the acquisitive
are just rumors right now but it all
sounds very plausible and like I've said
before I'm gonna be doing weekly Star
Wars rebels videos as soon as they start
airing episodes that's supposed to be in
October so as long as you watch those
you'll learn all about the inquisitors
in their role inside the empire stay
tuned for an exact date they haven't
announced when it's gonna start airing
but I will say in a future video
whenever I find out so the next big news
is some Han Solo Hoth art that posted
its old Han inhofe gear it implies that
will see Hoth in the movie but most of
the talk is about how authentic the
images were and whether or not the
insignia on his jacket was changed from
the original Empire Strikes Back
insignia supposedly there's not gonna be
any new Republic in the movie so there's
still part of the rebellion for those
that didn't read the expanding universe
novels the New Republic was just the
government that rose from the ashes of
the Empire like between ten to fifteen
years following Return of the Jedi
they are ditching like a whole lot of
expanded universe stuff but that doesn't
mean that we won't see Marge eight or
other big fan favorite things there was
some confirmation that the rebels
cartoon was going to use the Rex droid
from the original Disneyland Star Tours
ride I couldn't consider that to be
expanding universe so there is hope for
them including some expanded universe
things so onto really cool Rian Johnson
stuff for those who don't know he was
hired to write and direct Star Wars
Episode eight that's gonna be in 2017
and it's like the Empire Strikes Back of
the new trilogy he just did a really
cool podcast with my friend Emily at
Grant Land and they mentioned some
really awesome things from behind the
scenes of Episode seven
I added direct links to said podcasts
along with clear links to Emily in the
description so make sure you check those
out
she has hands-down one of the smartest
people I know and her podcast girls and
hoodies is so much fun she does a lot of
cool science fiction and pop-culture
writing so if you do check it out
be sure to leave them a nice comment and
tell them emergency awesome sent you so
just to summarize Bryan Johnson said
that he's spent a lot of time on set
with JJ Abrams on Episode seven just
seeing what they were doing with that
movie he said he got so excited when he
saw how much of the movie is being shot
on old school physical sets like they're
building big egg swings the Millennium
Falcon just like they did for the
original trilogy they're building most
of their sets it's gonna give Episode
seven this amazing tactile feeling that
I think a lot of us felt was missing
from the prequels just because most of
those movies were shot digitally on
green screen and if you look at some of
the pictures that JJ Abrams has been
posting from the movie you can see a lot
of creatures and real-life big sets in
the background it almost makes me feel
like Jim has
and came back to life and started making
cool new Star Wars puppets I think of
all the things that I'm hoping to see in
the new movie you know mostly our han
and chewie doing old-school scoundrel
comedy a couple of twists on jokes from
the original trilogy and then there's
this lesser rumor that Oscar Isaac wins
tumble in him from Han in a card
game and he has to get it back I'd
really love to see Luke Skywalker doing
something really really crazy with the
force that we've never seen before in
Brienne of Tarth Wendell and Christie
just being a badass Inquisitor
supposedly she's gonna be one of the
Sith warriors like imagine Gwendoline
Christie if she were playing the Hound
or you could even dial it up and make
her a freakin crazy version of the
mountain with a lightsaber I could talk
all day about stuff I'd love to see in
the movie I just hope that they don't
get too nostalgic I'm really hoping to
see some new things that we've never
seen before I'm actually more excited to
see Rian Johnson's Empire Strikes Back
you know his episode 8 the second movie
a trilogy is always the best or maybe
most of the time is the best if you
haven't watched any of his movies watch
looper and brick those are definitely
two my favorites and be sure to check
out my friends podcast
feel free to shower her with
congratulations and praise as long as
it's nice her partner Molly Lambert is
also totally amazing I don't know her in
real life but I am also a big fan of
hers in case you missed it I was running
a Star Wars Funko pop giveaway during
Comic Con congratulations to shadow
artist you get your choice of Star Wars
Funko pop I'll message you on your
channel for details
so my next Star Wars video is gonna be
for rebels they basically posted like a
giant chunk of the first episode for you
to watch online for free so I'll be
doing a review that be sure to subscribe
to get that video in the meantime you
can click here to watch this week's core
video I'll be sure to add the annotation
as soon as I post it some serious
went down and you can click here to get
my last big breakdown of Star Wars
rebels thank you so much for watching
I'll see you guys tomorrow
high fives